so the wireless industry can be a
deceptive Place free phone promotions
expensive multi-line plans all hinged on
the hope that you the customer are too
complacent to look into something a
little less complicated so that's why
I'm here to tell you about visible
Wireless and how they're making it easy
to understand wireless service behold
the blue board pretty competitive right
nope what you're about to learn is uh
with the competitors things aren't
exactly how they seem to get the other
guys close to visible rate you got to
sign up for a family plan so that's
multiplied by three to get just one
you're going to have to pay way more and
then is an also fun part of all the
other onetime and monthly fees so with
their pink competitor here there are
quite a few with visible it's still just
25 bucks a month every month now here's
what you're going to pay every month now
this varies state byst state visible
works the taxes and fees into their rate
they work everything into their rate
with visible you really just pay the 25
bucks a month that they advertise with
the other guys not so much or should I
say so much nice work visible